okay let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 why don't we start with our
caller from the 7 1 7 area code caller
from 7 1 7 tell me who you are and where
you're calling from
um David hey David where you calling
from
I don't know I'm a definitely shuriken
video you know did my heart rate down
you know never would call it into a show
for alright good but so your name is
David or it's not David my name is
Nathan absolutely your name is Nathan
okay yeah I thought you'd been watching
my show us a little bit great I grew up
in a very right-wing family but iced
over like they got left-wing politics
through the show and Kyle kolinsky show
and I mostly agree with you a lot of
things but like one thing I have a hard
time like understanding your point of
view is immigration right okay well I
got you see if there are people I see
something like writing people are a
little bit little bit dehumanizing to
language wait we go big dreams is a
little bit like the car taking away the
magic it kind of hurt but um but like I
mean I understand we're treating the
well but also certainly house laws right
because if people come in across the
border um well well I thought they
should I definitely for immigration
before I think they should be easier if
people come here because they want
refugees right
yeah but Nathan let me just I mean let
me cut right to it who is saying that
there should be no border control and no
immigration laws I haven't heard anybody
say that
oh no yeah that's like that's I got a
quite link I true but was doing that's
like so yeah but only like only very
famous Mustangs aboard for open borders
and I never do agree with yes I also
know there's no reasonable chance that
totally opened board I mean totally open
borders is not being considered
seriously in any way so I questioned the
value of I mean of course you disagree
with that I disagree with that but it
seems that we should really be focusing
the discussion on the sort of more more
real world disagreements that there are
in other words when the president talks
about s whole countries and where people
should be coming from or when we talk
about the idea of building a wall and
what it means financially and what it
means in other ways it seems
yes sir some people might want totally
open borders but there's zero chance
that's going to be a reality and I don't
even know
we would sort of or even spend time
arguing against that well Martin we want
that one thing like I feel like our
borders will be under secured that
people can I walk across an on/off or a
wall and if that back straight yeah it's
a waste of money but um I would be for
it maybe like increasing border security
as far as the finding the Berkut always
trying tighter but I think I'll be good
not really just the idea that like the
border is that the career services
border is the way it should be perfect
what is your position no sir so we've if
we want to control more of what is
happening illegally at the border and
more generally with immigration with
more generally with immigration we need
to look at what's happening with
overstayed visas which represent a huge
portion of people that are here
illegally they're not crossing the
border at the border most of the drugs
are coming through ports of entry so of
course we should use both technology and
people whether it's Border Patrol
customs whatever and and mostly
Democrats are in favor of that so again
I feel like we want to be really careful
when you say you disagree with me so far
it sounds like we agree 100% okay they
understand your position but on that
could be but yeah I think that like
people good at this I think that
connects with his claims always cross
the border but I just want article with
that's clearly not border yes that's all
agree Nathan listen I'm gonna let you go
because it does sound like you're
underwater and I don't know what's
causing that but I do appreciate the
phone call and I look forward to
welcoming you back on the program
once again in the future